واعتقد عبد الرحمن اشير له نقطه مرت جدا
مهمه انه هذه تعطيه مشروعيه وتعطي الخطاب
السابق حضور حتى بالوعي الباطن انه انه
هذا الشخص اذا لاحظ لاحظ نقطه مهمه جدا
انا اذكر في حجر الزاويه كتبت وقتها مقال
وكان هو يعلق على المقالات اللي تكتب عن
البرنامج وكان يتحدث عن التغيير
زمن التغيير
كانت بالضبط
فكان تساءلي انه يا سلمان العوده امامك
الضمير الاخلاق للصحوه
انقذه
هذا التغيير يحدث
كانت اجابته مسجله كانت اجابته انه الجميع
اخطا في تلك المرحله هذه ترى اجابه خطيره
جدا لانه حينما
تعمم الخطا
يختفي هذا الخطاب
التحتي الذي يهيا لهذه التنظيمات وانا
اربط ايضا هذا الكلام ترى كله تاثير يوسف
العياري في مؤسسه تنظيم القائد مؤسسه
تنظيم القاعده الذي وقتها قتل يعني بعد
بدايه العمليات تحدث في رساله وهو هارب
وملاحق ويوجه خطاب لسلمان عوده يقول كيف
تتخلون عنه انتم الذين علمتمونا سمعنا
اشرطتكم جالسناكم حظر المحاضراتكم ثم
تنقلبون الان علينا
عيسى العوشن وهو ايضا قائد اعلامي وشرعي
في التنظيم القاعده وقتل في
يوليو 2004
قال في رساله تابينيه مكتوبه منشوره ان
يوسف العياري قال له
حينما كان يوسف اسامه بن لادن في السودان
حينما انتقل السودان او رجع هو وقابل
سلمان العوده قال حدثوا عن اسامه بن لادن
ونشاطه قال انني اتشرف ان اكون تحت اداره
اسامه بن لادن هذه نصوص ناشرينها يعني
وهذه مقولات تقالوها وتحدثوا فيها بالتالي
الرابط بين الخطاب الصحوي والتنظيمات
المتطرفه الارهابيه هو استمرار لما بين
الفكر وبير التنفيذ عبد الرحمن اشار نقطه
هامه قبل قليل انه لما تم التعامل مع هذه
القيادات الصحويه التي تقول احنا مش قاعده
سواء بالمحاكمه سواء بعضهم هرب بره بعضهم
الان التزم الصمت بعضهم حول حتى يقدم نفسه
باسلوب جديد صحيح
الوضع في البلد معناته اللي تفضلت فيه عبد
الرحمن انه معناته في رابط سببي الشيء ان
المقدمه تؤدي الى النتائج صحيح يعني لو
هدا هدا الموت او على الاقل هو جزء من
الاسماء بالاضافه الى اجراءات اخرى وفي
يعني هذا هو الخطاب خطورته يعني انه احد
احد القيادات
المؤثره يعني قال بعد سنوات من التفجيرات
قريبه يعني وهو استاذ جامعي ايضا قال
تنظيم القاعده لم يعني لم يتورط في الدماء
كانه في كوكب اخر والتفتيرات حدثت في قلب
الرياض وفي المدن السعوديه
استدرك قال احضروا لي كتب
احسن الظن يا استاذ وهذه الخطوره وهذه
الخطوره حينما يستمر هذا الخطاب او يبقى
تحت يعني السجاد ثم يخرج في لحظه ما بدون
ان يخرج واعي يفكك هذه المنظومه الفكريه
كيف نشات وكيف تطورت حتى وصلت الى هذه
المرحله وهذا ما طلبت فيه حتى الذي حتى
الذين اعتذروا لم يفككوا الخطاب اعتذروا
فقط كلام انشائي